hey what's up guys my name is samuel and
i'm amanda and this is the samuel and
amanda show where we talk about money
marriage and life and in this week's
episode we are going to be asking one
another apparently the 15 most
controversial questions you can ask in a
marriage you're looking scared oh
you don't i didn't know yeah i don't
know
now this is not a property related video
tonight this is more about money
marriage life but in this
on today is controversial questions now
i've read the questions and to be
perfectly honest don't worry they are
not controversial okay this is an
opportunity for you to get to know us
just a little bit better on a more
personal way so are you ready i'm ready
all right also don't forget if you
enjoyed the channel please do hit the
like button also if you've got questions
that you want to ask for me or amanda
then comment below in the comment box so
first question is this
if you could relive a year in your life
what age would you choose
oh i would choose
when i was 23 so that's when we were
together i'm glad i'm glad
you just said 20 i'd have been a little
bit worried okay so i graduated that
year with a first class honors and uh
also it was on the same meet you
proposed no we were gonna be getting
married and that's the year we got
married so i graduated and then
literally seven days later that's when
we got married and that was just like
amazing it was like
yeah really big moments in my life i
would probably relive to be honest i'm
really enjoying 2021 so i wouldn't
necessarily want to really the year but
if i had to it would probably be
20 20 2018 was a good year 2018.
what made it good
um
and then she was born in 2017. and then
you were pregnant with luke
so it was like we're growing a family oh
yeah true okay good scene
have you ever been in a studio audience
for a tv show
no
i have mine lewis you're amazing mine
which of your parents do you like them
no
it's not that would that would be
controversial actually not controversial
actually which of your parents are you
most like i thought it was gonna be do
you like oh yeah i know that would be
controversial which of your parents are
you most like
oh
i'd probably say i'm like my mom
definitely yeah like your mum yeah for
me
yeah i think you're a mix i think yeah
you really are a bit of birth you're not
more like either which of your siblings
are you most like
my brother ben yeah we are cool calm and
collected you and your three brothers
me and my brother were the same yeah um
what's a new hobby you've always wanted
to try
i would love to learn how to sew and
like make my own clothes
why don't you then
i don't know i mean my hobby that i want
to do
thank god that's something that i
actually
have really been trying but it's
difficult because it's weather dependent
i want to paraglide
but every time i've booked it it's been
cancelled because of the weather and
also you need to put like a lot of time
aside you've got the mountains
i've booked like three times it keeps
getting cancelled but sewing i mean joey
yeah i know i just haven't it's time
consuming babe i just haven't if you won
the lottery what would you do with the
money
oh if i won the lottery
i don't know
life
[Music]
um what would you do with a week of
solitary confinement
well i'd probably just read books
because i like reading you're allowed to
dedicate astrology confinement i guess
you are well it's asked me what i'd like
to do oh you can wear a blank wall i
probably read a book yeah i mean what
about if you were in scientific
confinement but you won't have anything
in the room besides
like a duvet and
someone just put food in like basically
i'd probably just sing
sing yeah
i would use it as a week to think i'd be
like wow but there's only so much
thinking you can do and if you're
planning you can't even write down
anything it's how you're going to
remember so you might as well not do
that strategize
come out
richer wiser
wow i mean i mean not enough to want to
actually do it but you got you're gonna
make them make the motion situation
right
okay um what's another career that you
would enjoy
so if we couldn't do property or um you
being a mom i guess like what career in
another world in another world
in another world would be a dentist
okay
because i just i don't know because i
love teeth i just think you can
transform someone by changing their
teeth i think it's just really mighty
changed
you could have them straightened a bit
i think i need something um in another
world you'd be a dentist oh i think in
another world i would be
a lawyer
you'd be a very good lawyer sarah will
be a really good lawyer i love the law
yeah i think you'd be great and i love
arguing
and thinking and i just i'd love to be a
lawyer
in fact maybe i should just become a
lawyer
i would be surprised imagine that career
change what do you think if i just said
i want to be a lawyer
i just think cool i just think with
being a lawyer it's one of those jobs
that
i just think it's really strange because
if you're on the defendant side it's a
bit ropey i just think oh how can you
literally fight for someone that you
might know believe has done this crime
but you're defending them i just think
it's a bit of a
yeah but i think when dentists give like
root canals and stuff
no maybe maybe not maybe it's not
putting metallic people's teeth and
things
we're judging each other it's probably
best that we just probably know thank
god
all right next question what genre of
books would you spend the most time
reading through in
a bookstore
okay you always go to the personal
development
sucker you always literally samuel will
go into like a shopping sp smith and
then he'll be like okay i'm gonna go to
zara and he'll be like oh i'll just stop
in here and you can find me back in here
when you're finished and you'll
literally just be in the book store just
like reading i love it you'll find me
when we go shopping which we are about
to go shopping now yeah
you will find me in the bookstore yeah
devouring the business books yeah
books i just love it and also i only
have to skim give me a book for like
three minutes and i've basically read it
i just skimmed read it so when i go to a
bookstore i just read i'm just like i'm
like a kid in a candy shop i love going
in book stores but what about you in a
bookstore
i would probably go to personal
development but then also probably just
look at people's biographies
yeah how many telephone numbers have you
actually memorized
oh my goodness i only know your number
but i actually i'm still learning your
new number so
i don't know my new number i know my new
number a little bit now i know my old
number really well yeah i know your
number and i know russell's number and i
know my mom's number oh really maybe i
should learn a few more then just in
case okay do you think you would make a
good politician
no and i have no interest like to me i
always think when i see people i'm like
why are you drawn to doing this like to
me it's just like the worst job ever it
does not appeal to me what i have no
interest i see i really do oh i just
don't get it what's so oh the thing is
it's not about the obviously it's a
horrible job everyone hates you and
you're a politician yeah but it's if you
want to bring i like to bring about
change and i like to help improve the
world and the economy and if i see
something that i don't like i like to
actually change it and i think as a
politician you're in a position where
you can do that to some extent so
although it would be very
um
hard and although it would be difficult
because everybody hates you um i think
that
for me i could potentially see myself
being a politician
i could see you as a politician and a
lawyer
and a power glider jack of all trades
all right what is something you hated as
a kid but now i appreciate
i can't think of anything really serious
but
i used to not like tea
but i love cups of tea now
i was thinking more like like church or
something like that a bit well i never
hated going to church like i didn't mind
i just went with the flow
what about being told by your parents
that you couldn't do stuff like
um
being
sorry about that what about being told
by your parents you can't do stuff and
at the time you hate it but then when
you go oh do you appreciate why you were
talking okay so something a bit deeper
oh yeah okay that makes sense
so
i mean i can think of lots of moments
like that one that i can think of now
off the top of my head
is for example now that i have children
especially girls
i can see why my dad was so protective
over me and boys play with boys girls
play with girls that was my dad's line
all the time literally boys play with
boys girls play with girls
and to me when i was young i didn't get
it i was just like i just don't
understand what the big deal is just
want to play with
this person yeah but now i totally
appreciate and i'm so i'd much rather
and i'm so grateful that my dad was like
overly that way yeah then maybe just
like i don't know sometimes you can end
up in positions where you know you can
be compromised and yeah so now i
appreciate that
so all right a few more questions i hope
you're enjoying if you are hit like who
was your favorite teacher in high school
and why
i don't remember any of my teachers
i remember i had i remember i had mr
moon for english literature and he was
he was a nice guy but my favorite
teacher was definitely mrs hay smith who
actually made it to the daily mail yes
she did because she was my favorite
teacher and then when i left school i
saw that she was actually kind of
struggling financially and i mentored
her in property and now she's
financially free as a property investor
which is incredible so she's now become
a well-known property investor she's
just the most amazing person ever so if
you're watching mrs hay smith i love you
always and forever i'm eternally
grateful all right um two more questions
no no no three three three would you
rather skydive bungee jump parasail or
hang glide
none of the above please for me
i would do all of them i have many of
them yeah bungee's my favorite
what was the kindest thing a stranger
has ever done for you oh
kindest thing
can you think i'll have a little i can
think of a thing yet i can it was a
small thing but i remember i was in a
car park and i couldn't um i didn't have
the change to pay for parking i was in a
real rush rush and i was like stressed
stressed out and i was there like ah at
the car park and this lady came up to me
and just said oh are you okay and i was
like oh i'm just i'm just trying to get
the car park and it was like two pounds
or something and she just went oh you're
going she gave me two pounds and i just
thought i don't know why but that was
probably about 10 years ago and it just
stuck with me so again if you are
watching let me return you a hundred
times
now i'm gonna have all these people
pretending i remember what she looks
like honestly oh my gosh i can't think i
can't think of a moment
in particular i feel like people always
really nice to me but especially when
i'm pregnant that's when people i feel
like extra extra nice they're like oh
let me get that for you when you're in
the shop and stuff so
last question
what song could you karaoke to
oh my goodness wow this brings back lots
of bad memories
raw topics bad memories so when we went
on a cruise
and
i mean i'm quite fun and i love karaoke
so there was a karaoke night and i was
like oh babe we need to go and do this
we get there there's only a few people
there like an old couple
like you know like whatever anyway i was
like sign me up i'm gonna give these
guys a show and what song did i do oh is
beyonce single ladies what happened was
um amanda chose beyonce and she actually
chose a really hard song to sing because
they're actually single ladies it is a
really tough song to see yeah but mandy
was thinking well be a laugh it'd be fun
however you were like
i was the third
oh my goodness first of all who takes
karaoke that seriously carries he's
supposed to be like ha they can't sing
but huh they're having to go anyway it's
fun but you actually can't sing you've
got a nice form yeah yeah but compared
to these people so the first couple i
can't remember only i don't know if they
sang like a sure and sunny song but it
was like really really nice but they
were old and it was like oh but they're
really good the second girl she was
maybe like a teenager and she sang at
last wow you really remember this well
yeah yeah she said this was years ago by
the
way
amanda scarred me she sang at last and
she was phenomenal it literally was like
watching an x-factor perform
professional she was very she was
outstanding and then now i'm thinking
omg these people have sang actually like
seriously performed
now i'm going up to sing single ladies
oh my gosh
it was one moment a great